par un pêcheur étudiants chômeurs la
france était en situation pré
révolutionnaire pour en parler
j'appelle un expert louis saez
non non non non
7 c'est un nouveau procès où une révolte
peut-être pas du tout majesté c'est une
émission de télévision
vous êtes et bon voyage visant genre
perdait la tête
qu'est ce que vous faisiez quand josé
téléporté dans cette émission quelle
question
nous étions morts bien sûr si vous est
demandé de venir majesté c'est parce que
la france est en situation pré
révolutionnaire vous êtes un expert
quand même non c'est ce qu'on peut voir
un petit peu frigide d'ailleurs ça va
devoir assurer un monsieur leroi parce
que de votre temps les gens voulaient
seulement du pain regardez aujourd'hui
ils veulent du pain et des jeux vidéo
des magnétoscopes et des appareils de
photo qui coûtent la peau
et puis casse tout en plus vous savez
pour monsieur balladur ben ça va pas
être simple de distribuer tout ça comme
des petits pains en situation pré
révolutionnaire vous y connaissez quand
même un petit peu c'est vrai ça nous
rappelle des souvenirs
enfin si nous pouvons vous aider et vous
faire part de votre expérience
quel est le régime actuellement la
république majesté et comment ça se
passe le peuple vote et
le gouvernement exécute exécute exécute
qui pas seulement les lois
vous me rassurer mais quand le peuple
change d'avis mais ils votent pour
d'autres hommes politiques
quoi d'autre dynastie n'ont pas de dîner
si palaiseau relais rassurez vous mais
de gaulle pompidou giscard mitterrand
enfin un coup à droite un coup à gauche
quoi
mais dites moi ça nous a l'air est
patent votre système
enfin en ce moment c'est un peu tendu a
quand même fait des manifs rien ne
marche
la loi falloux air france les marins
pêcheurs des étudiants enfin le meuble
un peu révolté là quand même
et si vous lui accorder le droit de
grève c'est déjà fait les quatre
semaines de vacances par an s'est déjà
fait un mk mans 5 6 7 1 le robot se vend
d'hermès et déjà c'est la sécurité
sociale ça s'appelle tu nous commençons
à a peiné et bien ozon rozon offrez lui
une seconde république et déjà la
cinquième sac république
depuis que nous sommes partis mais ces
deux là c'est de la gourmandise
rafa ça s'appelle la démocratie alors ne
voyons plus qu'une seule solution
avant quoi la révolution c'est un peu
violent quand même si l'on commence à
chipoter monsieur ardisson ou alors
choisissez un bon chef d'état un honnête
rassurant jamais un mot plus haut que
l'autre travail en date est ce qu'il
faut quasi clodo ouais mais ce sacrifice
scène où ça non ça c'est le premier
ministre edouard balladur balle est mal
à dire balladur ballamou balladur quel
drôle de nom
un nom d'emprunt elles sont superbes vos
clés il s'est démené c'est mes clés est
ce que tu conserves qui si elle
si les qte l'art les débats terre les
placards de sa gamme et auriez vous
l'amabilité nous les aux fruits bastien
votre seigneurie ses cd clé de boulot
c'est ainsi que les études après tout
lorsque je peux faire c'est pour vous
faire plaisir
tu peux aller au clae minutes et puis
hop le ramène à trous sont tout neufs
tandis minutes tout neuf que minutes du
doubs oui c'est qu'ils ne connaissaient
pas les clés minutes votre seigneurie
parce que vous comprenez ça il y en a
tous les coins de rue et des petites
boutiques qui ont fait d'excès pas
passer dix minutes évitent les mêmes
totalement révolutionnaire les nuits là
vous pensez que ça ferait un bon
président la république non il n'est pas
trop conservateur au moins un peu pour
ça qu'ils fassent attention les français
nous les connaissons ils nous en ont
fait voir de toutes les couleurs du
blanc royal au tricolore républicain à
la fois conservateur et révolutionnaire
des vrais hommes
ennuyeux ils ne savent jamais ce qu'ils
veulent nous price a explosé en france
non au moins deux mais pas su passer
orné de la cheville et provoque les
corps des sept à bientôt louis excusez
moi nous avions oublié nos clés et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de l'ina
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus